the three candidates had to convince
Scottish national party members on two
main issues they could deliver
Independence and use their current
powers to improve life for Scottish
people for front runner Hamza Yusuf that
meant building on the Scottish
government's Legacy as your first
Minister I will build on our
government's radical and Progressive
agenda for his opponents it meant
distancing themselves from that Legacy
the SNP has lost its way there's been no
progress on Independence it's time for
change continuity won't cut it use of
stewardship of a crisis hit Health
Service gave his cabinet colleague an
opportunity for one of the most
confrontational moments of the debate
when you were a transport Minister the
trains were never on time when you're a
Justice Minister the police were
strained to bake breaking point and now
as health Minister we've got record high
waiting times what makes you think you
can do a better job as first Minister we
are the only nation not to have had NHS
strikes this contest was sparked by the
surprise resignation last month a first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon she just had
a high-profile bill on reforming gender
recognition in Scotland struck down by a
veto by the UK government something
Hamza Yusuf is pledging to challenge in
court unlike Kate Forbes Yusuf
implicitly alluding to her devout
Christian faith let me just be honest
because it is about honesty that is your
opposition to the gr bill which I
respect because there's differences of
opinions on this panel if this was any
other bill you would be standing up to
the UK government because
my Approach here is that if we were
independent we wouldn't be asking
anybody's permission well the contest
has been dominated so far by differences
on social policy and public services the
overarching purpose of the SNP remains
to gain independence from the British
government here at Westminster but with
recent opinion polls in Scotland
suggesting a clear margin against
Independence there'll be plenty of
ground to make up on the party's core
mission for its new leader the
independence question did take up most
of the time in this debate Ash Reagan
arguing the that winning an absolute
majority for the SNP at The Ballot Box
provided a better chance than persuading
the UK government to hold another
referendum a referendum really is just
another way to use the ballot box and a
referendum is not the gold standard The
Ballot Box is the gold standard Hamza
Yusuf argued he was best placed to stand
up to Westminster Kate Forbes that it
was about showing economic competence
and persuading the unpersuaded none of
you has told your membership
the candidates have just under three
weeks to make that clearer Harry Fawcett
Al Jazeera London